logging in user guest 036
oh
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the home safety hotline
h-o-m-e-s-a-f-e-t-y-h-o-t-l-i-n-e
I don't know why I spelled that out you
remember analog horror you know
spooky stuff there's someone in your
house here's someone knocking at your
door
there's someone standing behind you
stuff like that this is not the typical
way that we deal with this this is how
we help other people deal with Invaders
in their home so
look at the commercials oh
oh
[Music]
so that's what we're all about we're
here at home safety hotline
we here at home safety hotline are going
to be helping other people get their
home safe
and stay away from all those horrible
things they're going to be calling me
and I'm going to be answering expertly
because I'm an expert
[Music]
wow ain't this beautiful
no
clocking okay thank you
oh man
please all right oh
[Music]
hello
hi
during your time here at hsh before you
begin your first day here let me tell
you a bit about how things work here
you are an hsh responder as such it is
your job to learn about various
household hazards so you can answer the
questions of our callers intelligently
when a client calls answer the call and
listen carefully to their concerns when
you diagnose their issue submit the
corresponding household Hazard and we'll
forward them safety instructions to
address their problem welcome to the hsh
family I'm sure we'll talk again soon
okay
thank you Carol
okay audios
[Music]
I'm not sure those are bees bee stings
in addition to blah blah blah blah black
mold
yeah that's not good does it have a
sound hey
hey what's up
[Music]
John here
it sounds like she thinks we might have
some kind of infestation my wife keeps
telling me
just looks like coffee
to me how am I supposed to know what it
looks like this is
this is I mean it's
is it is it black mold
I I think gopher
all right
I think he might be talking about black
mold pretty sure I'm gonna say black
mold
uh
all right another person safe from the
horrors of mold long-term danger regular
cleaning supplies
well that's nice
termites uh hi welcome to the hsh oh
you better not tell me it's nothing
again because I know I've seen something
moving
tell me what it is so I can take care of
it once and for all huge pile are you
talking about little literal crap are
you talking about
what do you do oh please oh all right
hold on it could be a mole
never kill a mole
gopher
I mean
I'm guessing it might be a mole mole
[Music]
I'm gonna go with mole
there we go I'm guessing I solved it I
don't know why more would be pooping
that much or why you must must never
kill a mole I mean I wouldn't want to
I'm not saying I want it but it's just
like that seems something weird to point
out like that you know okay well this is
great
um
hello welcome to the home safety hotline
my name hi
[Applause]
oh
I don't have that entry in my book
probably nothing to worry about and
definitely not something you guys need
to worry about ever
foreign
don't call me for help
[Music]
because of this annoying little sound
coming from my attic uh it sounds kind
of like
he
he you know it's probably nothing I'm
sure it could just be regular old house
noises but I just thought I'd call to
ask and make sure
you talking about b-e-e-e's
what about mises
[Music]
I mean that's probably it but I want to
say bees too it could be bees
[Music]
all right this is going great
nothing to worry about
[Music]
hi
hello oh
[Music]
just all over the place
uh whippersnappers yelping and whining
and uh
all right Buzz goober I don't know what
you mean okay
tick
hi
[Music]
kid is complaining about being too sick
to do anything about it
man stress of this stupid Lawns give me
a headache just think
you guys sent some guys up to get this
done
uh
uh please I I don't know I don't know if
that's in my
I I don't know if that's in my entry um
uh uh uh bees
geez
oh bees
all right that's what I'm all about here
yeah
uh I better not be Tim
[Music]
oh hi Carol
s to let you know that you've been
granted access to additional household
Hazard information oh
I'm just one of these hazards we will be
providing only information to the
clients that is pertinent to addressing
their concerns
thank you good to know permissions have
been updated wow bat all right carb
into the summer
carbon monoxide
I don't know where the common hob
[Music]
do you guys handle security I need home
security installed someone's breaking
into my house and going through all my
stuff at night
it's Bob from accounting he's always
been envious of me I know what you're
doing Bob going through my papers
talking to me with your organization
skills I need your best home security
equipment pronto
uh-huh okay please please hold
um
okay you got common hob you got your
desk Hobs
are capable of metamorphosizing all
right please hold
[Music]
uh-huh feast
a false beat
oh oh just just digestive issues and
back problems so it's like any parasite
okay whatever cannot be removed without
killing the host well just like any
other parasite so that's fine frozen
pipes
foreign
house fires
that's not good lamp Sprite
stare slug
wood secretions
well it sounds like you got some common
Hobbs
or a false beat but I'm gonna go with
common Hobbes
yes mobs
that's what I'm all about here at hsh
you take care of those Ops don't provoke
them whatever you do don't provoke them
oh
oh aha welcome to hsh
[Music]
friends
I don't remember what your problem was
and I don't know how I possibly couldn't
have solved it I solved it exactly and
precisely too hey
[Music]
sorry I'm
I'm sorry uh anything you can do to uh
prevent pollen from coming in the house
I think there's something seriously
wrong with my ventilation or something
because I like not stop sneezing
ah
fast I haven't had problems so long as
I've stayed inside but I think something
is getting in
um yeah please hold
um didn't I see something about sneezing
or allergies or something like that do
you have black mold
that's why I said that other guy Ed oh
do you have a musty smell
[Music]
that's what I'm here for
oh I guess that guy didn't that guy say
something about coffee grounds I guess
that could have been
ants
[Music]
hi
do you know if there's such a thing as
houses that clean like maybe to disguise
the robbery at night I keep hearing all
this noise coming from my living room
but when I go look at it I find the
place spotless
haven't you found anything missing
I've talked with the cops but they keep
telling me to call this number
so here I am is there something you can
do
common Hobb
could it be a hob do they clean they
have no false face
consume dirt
cleaning you've got a common hob
wow coming home you're welcome hunnigan
that's what I'm all about
[Music]
hello
info when I was
asking lawn care and my old family's
sick to our stomachs and itchy is all
get out
thank you
thanks for nothing jerk
I sent you this stuff about the bees I
feel like uh maybe you should have
heeded the warning
well all right I don't exactly know what
you needed there I didn't want to look
at it possibly you asked for lawn care
how was I supposed to help you
hello please don't be another wrong help
oh
I have never seen
salt
outside
you know I I don't know what am I gonna
do to make this right ah man okay I
you guys sawdust coming out your drawers
you talked oh but I was gonna help you
use carpenter ants maybe or termites
that was it
[Music]
hi
it's right there
hey
was it a stair slug
maybe it was a desk cob hello employee
employment period here has ended
remember that's all you've seen here is
strictly confidential
do not tell anyone what you have learned
here today our eyes rest upon me
we hope to work with you again soon
okay I think it's a desk Hub is your
problem okay
oh
ah
hi I'm concerned about the stability of
my new home
sorry my name is
probably nothing I think I just played
this
[Music]
Satan
well I was hoping to do a little
gooder
um anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching uh I look forward to this
full release when it comes out my
actions might have resulted in the death
of two people or more so Foos to say
anyway thank you uh let me know if you
want to see this game when it fully
comes out
right on
I'll see you bye-bye
[Music]